someone else you can do it all two-time
Grammy winner Michael Bolton the 65 year
old just up to the bromance Factor with
a new fragrance collection now I know
what everyone out there is thinking so
yes I went ahead and I asked him what
does Michael Bolton smell like Wow
okay fine I'll smell you Wow you ready
give it a try here we go
so brother Charles for dinner smells
like time love and tenderness the sweet
smell of success Michael's first ever
fragrance for women is named for one of
his biggest hits three house smell I
sprayed way too much were you in the
factory did you have all the smell tests
and all that stuff that individuals
smell test because we have these little
sample yeah pieces and fortunately we
got two quite a few that I really liked
for different reasons and agreed that
love was ready to happen and then
there's no double entendre there
Michaels also celebrating 50 years in
entertainment with a new album a
symphony of hits all his top tracks
re-recorded with an orchestra
but what you might be surprised to hear
is the man who brought us michael
bolton's big sexy Valentine's Day
special might need a little help in that
department this year do you have plans
for Valentine's Day no no plans hmm do
you need yeah come on yeah of course
yeah who do you want to meet I got the
rolodex we'll talk okay
[Music]